savigne sur lathan son église ses
anciens remparts son centre bourg son
club de boule de fort et sa grande
nouvelle du jour 4 millions 660 6667
euros exactement
c'est ce qu'a rapporté un ticket acheté
ici quelques jours avant noël nous
sommes dans la galerie marchande du
supermarché de savigné et valérie guéret
se souvient pour ce tirage du 21
décembre
les joueurs étaient nombreux une
centaine au total dans son commerce
parmi eux des clients venant à 90% de sa
vigne et où des villages voisins
c'est souvent qu'il ya des gros gars
entre 150 220000 donc c'est toujours un
petit peu d'émotion et puis on souhaite
à tout le monde
là 4,6 millions ces normes là ça fait
rêver
bien entendu la française des jeux ne
nous révélera pas le nom des gagnants
mais on sait aujourd'hui qu'il s'agit
d'un couple qui regardait ce jour là le
tirage du loto en direct à la télévision
leur projet finir la rénovation de leur
maison gâter leurs enfants et partir en
voyage vous êtes à la plus votre femme
oui oui parce que je savais qu'à
lesquels avaient joué le 21 mai je sais
je savais pas s'il était venu toucher
ouais mais non c'est pas mon nom
rassurez vous c'est pas moi ouais on
cherche à savoir on est curieux la
campagne au gpo jalou by opérateurs
c'est bien jacques fauteux l'on veut
venir chez vous je maintenant et ces
dernières années plusieurs commerces du
département ont validé de très beaux
ticket gagnant 3,5 millions 1 vous vrai
3,8 millions puis 4 millions à saint cyr
sur loire et enfin 65 millions d'euros
c'était taloche il ya deux ans pour le
tirage de l'euro millions